[Music] I
think it would be better to be with you guys as training,
it does
n't
look like it would be fun.  Oh
my God Jealousy No,
I wonder if Rain is in trouble.
It's okay,
Tanya's mean, but I don't hate her,
so it's already decided. Then Lain made a contract
with me, this
devotional contract, so it's only natural for me to make a contract with him, isn't it
?
Music]
Are you ready? No matter when,
we all have different names Make a
new contract Make a painting here Make a
vow
Hope in your heart
Power in this hand Give me the
answer What
is your name
[Music]
[Applause]  ] It's
over, the
contract is complete
Look, you've got a strange pattern on your hand, right?
I feel like
I've used Coke I made a contract with myself, but I can't think of anything You
're making a face